dear young Europeans and film lovers
thank you so much
and thanks to the European film Academy
and the jury
what an honor and what a powerful
message you are sending with this award
indeed movies can really pull at your
Heartstrings
they can make you laugh and cry
they can turn the spotlight on an
important issue
they can make people Embrace a cause and
that's exactly what our planet needs
right now
we all need to take action for our
climate
and that is the basic idea behind the
European green deal
yes the European Union can show the way
we've set targets and goals we're
investing massively in the transition
from fossil fuels to clean energy
but governments can only do so much
we need every person every community and
every industry to change
and let me tell you that I'm so glad
that the European film industry is
taking this commitment so seriously
because you have the power to change
hearts and Minds
and you can make people see that
everyone can make a difference for our
planet
I would like to dedicate this prize to
all filmmakers
that will bring our climate conscience
one step forward
thank you so much again Long Live Europe
and long-live European Cinema